What influence to think copper defense deficiency has on people have people supplemented it even though food or pill form how much how would you take?
Well, I do there is a
phenomenon
In a group of people that have copper deficiency, but by far by far it is outweighed by people who have copper toxicity
so
copper deficiency
exists
But copper toxicity is by far more common
So I'm not a big fan of taking an exogenous copper and let you test your zinc copper ratio and see what your levels are
So you don't you know one of the worst things with cancer is
The people have a copper toxicity, especially in certain types of cancer like prostate cancer and several other types of cancer
It's very common to have copper toxicity as a deficiency. I don't let any of my cancer patients take exogenous copper
Copper is going to be a feeder of growth
and
You know in all the years of taking care of cancer patients that never had a copper deficient patient so I know it exists
I know it ties to
Adrenal issues and some other issues, but you need to get a blood test and get it tested so I am not a fan of using
exogenous copper used that is copper in supplements
You'll see in our
Multimiderals and things only choose those that do not have copper. I don't that's one of the reasons why I don't like
Multiple vitamins for my cancer patients because they almost always have copper. They almost always have methylated
B vitamins, which is another no-no for cancer
And several other no-nose for cancer too
So to answer your question, what would you do with copper deficiency?
Well, first of all, you have to get it properly diagnosed. If you have it properly diagnosed and you do truly have a copper deficiency
Based upon the copper zinc ratio
Then you could suffer with copper, but that's not something I've ever had to deal with